it's here Disney has finally shown us
the first teaser trailer for Star Wars
Episode nine and most of the cast just
showed up to talk about the film at Star
Wars Celebration Stephen Colbert hosted
the panel and was also joined by
director JJ Abrams and Lucasfilm head
Kathleen Kennedy the film will be the
final movie of the Skywalker saga which
began more than 40 years ago with the
original Star Wars now titled a new hope
it will reunite stars Daisy Ridley as
Rey John boyega as Finn and Oscar Isaac
as Poe Dameron along with Adam driver
once again taking on the kylo Ren role
JJ Abrams confirmed some lines were
written based around Carrie Fisher
scenes from the force awakens so expect
to see general Leia Organa on screen one
more time also joining the film Lando
Calrissian yup
Billy Dee Williams is back as everyone's
favorite CardPlayer gambler and
scoundrel as our Kelly Marie Tran as
Rose Tico and Eunice Otomo as Chewbacca
also joining the cast Lady Macbeth's
Naomi a key whose character Janna is
rumored to be Lando's daughter some time
has gone by since the events of the last
Jedi with Abram saying the group goes on
an adventure together Daisy Ridley told
the audience that Rey may have gone
through some of the old Jedi books she
got from Luke Skywalker and that Luke's
lightsaber lives roast Tico will be out
of the coma we saw her in at the end of
last Jedi of course there are new
out-of-this-world creatures this is a
star wars movie after all and bb-8 is
getting a new friend do who looks like a
megaphone on a wheel at the end of the
panel Disney debuted their long-awaited
trailer the trailer opens but the sound
of Rey out of breath then we see her on
a desert planet probably her home of
jakku or luke's home of Tatooine we hear
Luke's voice say we
passed on all we now a thousand
generations live in you know which could
mean she has read the Jedi book she took
from Luke or has Raven getting Jedi
training from the force ghosts of Luke
Yoda and obi-wan we see Rey pull out her
lightsaber as Luke's voice says this is
your find and what looks like kylo ren's
tie silencer rapidly approaches then we
see a small ship approaching what looks
like a small city and a massless kylo
Ren leading a charge with a stormtrooper
by his side or is it race fight to save
him but then we see someone putting
kylos mask back together has Kyle truly
been lost to the dark side Poe and Finn
are also on the desert planet are they
looking for ray BBA and his new pal do
have the same head tool while Lando is
happily back in the cockpit of the
fastest hunk of junk in the galaxy then
we see Poe Finn and Threepio being
chased on the desert planet and a shot
of someone possibly Rey holding one of
the metals Luke and Han got from Leia
after the Battle of Yavin there's an
emotional embrace between Rey and
general Organa and Luke's voice saying
which is reminiscent of Obi Wan's the
force will be with you Luke always from
my new hope Luke's voice continues as
the team arrives at the remains of a
destroyed Star Destroyer or is it the
second theft star and then we hear the
evil laugh of Emperor Palpatine did he
somehow survive the destruction of the
second Death Star in Return of the Jedi
finally the title Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker but is that Skywalker going to
be kylo Ren Rey or both Rey was made to
believe she wasn't anyone in last Jedi
was she tricked
will she be revealed to be a Skywalker
hidden from kylo Ren the way Luke and
Leia were hidden from Darth Vader we'll
find out when episode 9 hits theaters
this December did we miss anything what
do you think are you excited or sad for
the Skywalker saga to officially come to
a close